if you haven't yet seen my video on the
index of hydrogen deficiency for
hydrocarbons take a moment to watch that
now determining unsaturation from a
chemical formula is simple enough when
we have a hydrocarbon but what happens
when other elements are present we know
from our bonding lesson that the most
likely elements in organic molecules are
concentrated in that upper right of the
periodic table carbon likes to make four
bonds when neutral nitrogen three oxygen
two and the halogens one for this part
of the lesson let's abbreviate the
halogens as X a very common abbreviation
okay if any of the elements I've shown
here are present we're going to need to
correct the saturated formula that we
originally calculate now for nitrogen
we're going to add one hydrogen atom to
the formula moving over one if we have
an oxygen atom do nothing to the
original saturated formula we won't add
or subtract anything at all now if there
are any halogens present in the formula
for each halogen subtract one hydrogen
atom
now this correction has to do with the
fact that nitrogen makes three bonds
oxygen two and the halogens one when
they are neutral let's see why by
looking at a few examples let's keep it
simple with examples containing two
carbon atoms ethane our saturated
hydrocarbon example is c2h6
and it looks like this okay so say we
add a nitrogen atom here we're going to
have to add one hydrogen to our
saturated formula giving us h7 okay
let's look at some possible structures
for this compound to figure out why we
had to add that H atom if we imagine
adding the nitrogen in the middle of
ethane we'll get this structure here's
our skeleton and nitrogen likes to have
three bonds when neutral so there's one
H atom coming off of it
if we count up our hydrogen atoms we
have three six seven there's one more
possibility for our structure if we put
the nitrogen at the end here's our
skeleton I filled in the hydrogen atoms
on carbon and then of course our
nitrogen likes to have three bonds it
needs to have two hydrogen's on it so we
have three four five six seven hydrogen
atoms in this structure as well all
right when we add an oxygen atom in we
don't have to change our formula so
let's look at c2h6o for our first
structure let's imagine popping the
oxygen in between the two carbons since
oxygen likes to make two bonds when
neutral when we pop it in there it has a
bond to each carbon atom and therefore
doesn't change the formula we don't need
to add or subtract any hydrogen's again
with this formula there's one more
possibility for the structure where we
put the hetero atom the oxygen atom on
the end our terminal carbon atom has
three hydrogen's to give it four bonds
this carbon needs two and we need to add
one hydrogen atom to oxygen since it
likes to have two bonds when neutral so
this structure which is dimethyl ether
or this structure which is ethanol are
both possibilities for c2h6o they
imagine we add a halogen now let's add
bromine when we do this we'll need to
subtract one H atom from our formula so
our formula is C 2 H 5b are the halogens
like to make one bond when they are
neutral so the only place we can put the
BR is on the end of the compound we
can't sandwich it in between two carbons
or anything like that so we'll just have
one structure we have one bond to this
carbon and two bonds to this so let's
fill in so that we have four bonds so
basically in this structure since
bromine makes one bond it's replacing a
hydrogen atom so we subtract one
hydrogen atom from our saturated formula
when we add bromine let's do a couple i
HD problems to be sure we have this down
for example 1 let's do C 2 H 4 o
remember our equation to figure out
saturated compounds is
- n + 2 filling in for 2 carbon and then
to correct for oxygen we do nothing so
this is going to be the number that we
use now let's do our ihd calculation so
we take our 6 expected hydrogen atoms
for the saturated formula subtract it by
the hydrogen's in our actual formula and
divide by 2
and this gives us a degree of
unsaturation of 1
so we can have one double bond or one
ring there are a few structural
possibilities for this formula let's
start by looking at double bonds first
let's imagine a double bond between the
two carbons we need to add two groups
onto this carbon this carbon already has
three bonds so we'll add one on and
oxygen likes to make two bonds when
neutral so we just need to add one bond
onto the oxygen filling in our hydrogen
atoms we can see we have four ok oxygen
makes two bonds when neutral so it's
possible the double bond is to the
oxygen atom that gives us this skeleton
we don't need to add anything onto
oxygen because it already has its two
bonds this terminal carbon needs three
groups and this central carbon has three
bonds and only needs one again let's add
in our hydrogen atoms so for our double
bond examples we have two possibilities
this compound which is called an e all
in this compound which is called an
aldehyde now it's also possible that we
have a ring we can pop an oxygen atom
into the ring because it bonds in two
directions we can see oxygen is
satisfied with its two bonds but we need
to add two bonds onto each carbon this
Epoque side also satisfies our
structural formula now let's do an
example where we need to correct our
saturated formula okay we have three
carbons let's plug that into our
equation here's our saturated equation
this will give us eight hydrogen atoms
but now we need to correct for bromine
so we need to subtract one hydrogen atom
from our calculation that we just did
this is because bromine is going to
replace a hydrogen atom so with our
correction for our saturated formula
we're expecting seven H atoms now let's
do our i HD calculation using this
corrected number so we have seven minus
five which gives us to divide that by
two and we have an I HD of one we have
three carbon atoms let's start by
drawing a structure that has a ring this
time each carbon is bonded two ways and
therefore needs two more substituents we
can put the bromine
on any one of the carbon atoms and then
fill in the rest of our hydrogen's we
can also have a double bond between
carbon atoms let's fill in four bonds
for each carbon atom now we have a lot
of possibilities for this compound the
bromine can be placed on any of these
carbon atoms and we get a distinct
compound if we place it on this terminus
the central carbon or this terminus
let's put it in the center as one of our
examples so with the double bond we have
our five expected hydrogen atoms and to
complete our story here are a couple
other structural possibilities by
putting the bromine in different spots
in this lesson we looked at how to
calculate the number of hydrogen atoms
on a saturated hydrocarbon using the
number of carbon atoms in the structure
we looked at how to correct our formula
for some of the common elements we'll
see in organic compounds we looked at
the structural origin of this and did a
few practice problems KP here if you
learn something give me a thumbs up on
the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel